in the beginning I was filthy I was
cussing I was dropping f-bombs
everywhere really yes a lot of people
don't know that I was a very dirty comic
when I first started remember I was
performing in bars dive bars it was Hood
I was in Montebello across the street
from the hospital which was very
convenient because people were getting
shanked all the time you know so like
he's gonna bleed out and I'll just cross
the hit the button across the light
right there go ER not don't get me wrong
because now but it's different it's
again it's not the whole show I'll drop
a couple things here and I'm a 47 year
old ball dude now so let's go I kind of
earned it a little bit you know but know
what it is that you want to talk about I
knew early on that I had this gift to
make people laugh I knew that the
characters and the sound effects and the
voices I needed to find a way to magnify
that but also be true to myself so once
I started telling stories I just
combined the characters the voices along
with the stories and that's why you
would hear this long ride and I learned
that that was my gift my gift wasn't set
up punch I can't do set up punch so when
people say write me some jokes or how
come you're not on a roast that's not my
thing yeah I